the 20/20 Oscar nominations were
announced today there were nine nominees
in total for Best Picture including Jojo
rabbit once upon a time yeah
once upon a time in Hollywood 1917 the
Irishman and Joker so really no huge
surprises there ah
think hard O'Brien be there any other
nominees well there's a couple yeah Ford
versus Ferrari was nominated to curse of
the Kraken what's the problem
do you feel that folks Avenger tying
down your mizzenmast because the wind
she's blowing in an icy cold snub you're
obviously a lighthouse captain and you
want to talk about the movie the White
House is at it the lighthouse no I've
never heard of that the lighthouse was
Willem Dafoe I just figured you were mad
because people expected the lighthouse
to be nominated but it wasn't no my
Bloods are boil because there is nary a
nomination for the year's finest film
Hobbes and Shaw you're talking about the
fast and furious movie the very one yes
twas a fine entry in the extended fast
and furious cinematic universe I it had
it all Hobbs
Shaw tires steering wheels gear shifts
mufflers yeah I'm gonna cut you off cuz
you're now you're just you're just
listening car parts did I say tires you
did you said look I'm sorry the Oscar
nominations didn't go your way
well tell me this O'Brien surely they
nominated at least one female director
this year correct actually no they did
not they did not great Neptune's tits
this is an outrage Greta Gerwig deserves
her dues yes sir thank you yeah you're
obviously yeah very upset sir I should
say though you especially you really
should see the movie the lighthouse well
tell me true O'Brien is the rock in it
no no he's not then I shan't be seeing
it
I won't fine then No what are you doing
here a free plug for your show watch
Conan weeknights at 11 p.m. on TBS not a
second of air time wasted
she's as tight as a drum
[Music]
you